Do you get hot and bothered when your date
throws up on their food and slurps it all
down?
Then you my friend may be a flyosexual.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
My dad always warned me that flies were the
scum of the earth and that I should NEVER
(i repeat: NEVER) allow them to land on my
food.
They’ll vomit!
They’ll poop!
They’ll spread contagious diseases and you
will die!
Felt a bit like receiving an abstinence lecture,
to be honest.
In a recent survey, Orick asked participants:
“if you were at a restaurant, which critter
would make you drop your fork?
Rodents?
Cockroaches?
Flies?
Ants?
Or snakes?”
SNAKES!
I’d definitely be atta that joint in a heartbeat.
61% of people said they would bounce if they
saw cockroaches, but scientists warn that
FLIES are actually twice as germy as cockroaches.
And they’re specifically referring to those
pesky houseflies that can be found anywhere
- after all, there are over 90,000 different
species of flies.
So what’s the real deal on flies and food?
Flies do gross things like eat garbage and
poop and rotting animal carcasses.
All those germs from the gross stuff they
think is delicious gets transferred to their
legs and small hairs all over their body.
It only takes a second for them to transfer
those germs to your food or to your body.
It’s also true that flies can’t chew,
so in order to eat, they spit enzymes on their
food to dissolve it and then slurp it up.
And yet another truth is that flies can carry
cholera, dysentery, and typhoid.
But...notice most people DON’T get those
diseases...which brings me to the rational
side of things.
Flies that are festering on food can definitely
make you sick, so if there’s a bunch of
flies feeding on a rotting apple - you probably
shouldn’t eat it!
But when they land on food for a few seconds,
it’s unlikely that it’ll transfer enough
bacteria to make you sick.
It’s also a misconception that they poop
every time they land.
That would be a lot of tiny fly bowel movements.
They might spit or vomit on your food if they’re
intending to eat it, but it’s the bacteria
that’s stuck to their body that actually
spreads disease and makes people sick.
Long story short: fly vomit is your friend,
fly bodies?
Not so much.
Thanks for watching DNews - do you get grossed
out if flies land on your food?
Let me know down below and we’ll catch you
on the next episode - hopefully with a little
less feces.